if you're watching newsletter you've
probably seen the video of uh
second lieutenant quran rosario on the
news with the police officers
in the back going in asking him to go
out and his hands are out this video is
from an event that took place december
5th
of 2020 which recently surfaced about
seven days ago
it's got 9 million views we watched it
today on the podcast we all had an
opinion on it last night i watched the
whole
31 minute from four different angles
with my family at my house till 10
o'clock at night
so we decided to reach out to the
attorney jonathan arthur agreed to be a
guest today
with us on valuetainment jonathan thank
you so much for being a guest on
valuetainment
thank you for having us we're having a
guest first of all
obviously a a tragic event i have the
video here that we'll get into here in a
minute because i want to get your
commentary on it but
if you don't mind for for some of the
folks that haven't seen it obviously
it's 9 million not 330 million views so
there's many people that probably
haven't seen what happened to it
walk us through what happened that
evening
when lieutenant coron nazario was going
home or where he was going so the clock
to the you know viewers can get an idea
what took place that night
so it was you know it was december in
virginia and it was about six o'clock so
it was dark outside couldn't see much
and uh you know the lieutenant
lieutenant azaria was coming back from a
military
operation he had some some military
commitments and he was headed home
and uh lieutenant crocker excuse me not
lincoln crocker
officer crocker from the windsor police
department decided that he was going to
initiate a traffic stop
allegedly because my client didn't have
planes
right and it was a new vehicle it was
like a 20 20 20
tahoe that my client had gone out of
state to purchase because he liked the
package
and the dealer had put the temporary
license plate while we waited for the
new well my client waited for the new
one
or the real put it up in the window in
any event
croaker decides that my clients didn't
have a license plate and just
initiate a traffic stop and you know
that's kind of problematic because when
they get out to the uh
to the gas station where my client
ultimately pulls over
you can see in everybody's body worn
camera footage that the license plates
visible in the rear mirror
or the rear window where it was so
460 at this point is four lanes and it's
dark
so my client decides you know let's do
the reasonable thing let's do what we're
all told
and let's wait till this well-lit open
area to pull over for everyone's safety
right
it's just common sense so and then
we get we'll get into this we get into
the body camera body-worn camera footage
but
my client to me you know the officer
hits his light so my client slows down
and you can actually see even though
there's no audio in the first 30 seconds
you can see
initially then past this amazon uh
tractor trailer and then the lights go
on and the amazon tractor trailer passes
by them so you just get this visual
reference
that my client slows down then we get
audio
and on the audio you have officer croker
crocker however you pronounce his name
calling out speeds so we get this
confirmation that everyone knows
gutierrez
dispatch us now that my client is
traveling below the speed limit and he's
actually slowing down
so this goes on for a mile
a little over a mile i think like 1.1
miles some negligible distance
over about a minute and a half minute
and 40 seconds
my client pulls over to the brightest
thing he can see which is
a bp gas station he pulls over
and what he doesn't realize is that for
some reason notwithstanding the officers
acknowledging that he's slowing down
right he has a turn signal on you see
the traffic
passing they decide to initiate this i
want a felony traffic stop
and they call it on the radio before he
even pulls over so
my client pulls over turns the car off
puts it apart turns the car off what
have you and starts hearing
you know commands and man put your arms
up the hands out the window and he looks
over
and for some reason he sees two officers
and these officers already have their
pistols out
and it's terrifying so
in order to unfortunately i think his
words are to preserve for posterity just
in case we have to figure out what
happened after
he's dead he starts recording and then
he puts his hands out the window
so these officers start yelling
inconsistent commands to them you know
one of them is able to put your hands
out the window put your hands out the
window put your hands out the window the
other one's yelling
get out of the vehicle now if you're
seat belted and your door's locked and
your hands are out the window like this
i'd really love for somebody to explain
to me
how you're supposed to keep your hands
out the window at the same time done to
your seat belt right i can't wrap my
head around how to do it any of that
so my client video cam videotaping with
his arms as far as he can get him out
the window because the seat belts
holding him in place
just calmly asks what's going on
the officers continue to shout it's
confusing because one of them's yelling
keep your hand get your hands out the
window when they're body worn camera
footage and my client's sofa footage
already show
his hands are out the window so this
exchange goes on for a few seconds maybe
30 seconds until officer former officer
joe gutierrez
you know responding to my client saying
hey what's going on says you're fixing
to ride the lightning son
so i heard that yeah and around here
that
is a colloquial expression for death by
electrocution in the electric chair
so we have this state organ threatening
to kill a man
for a traffic stop and there's also this
all racial undertones
given that the death penalty in
unfortunately this state throughout much
of this country is asymmetrically
applied to african-american men
so my client you know he threatens to
kill my client
starts yelling every now and they both
are yelling get out of the car my client
says hey
you know quite frankly i'm afraid to get
out of the car and that's reasonable
you've got two officers
bowman rabbit at the mouth with their
guns out one of them's just threatened
to kill you
so you think the officers would have
said oh no no it's okay we're just here
for a traffic stop or something like
that instead one of the officers says
yeah
you should be right just confirming and
it's the same officer that threatened to
kill
he's the one that says he's the one that
says i was a corporal in the marines and
his wife was
a admiral admiral i think not an admiral
a navy sailor for retired navy sailor is
who his wife
he alleges that he was in the marine
corps um you know i was in the marines
you were the 101st
yep on our first right so you know i
think we would all like to hope he's
lying
is that uh is that been confirmed or no
you guy have you guys confirmed that
that he was or no
so no i know it's one of the things i'm
going to take a look at but at the
moment
because all this is developed so quickly
we don't have subpoena power quite yet
but rest assured we're gonna look you
mind if we look at the video together
and if you can give us commentary of
your client of what he was saying is
that okay with you
uh sure okay i've watched this video now
multiple
times uh with my family with our peers
here
and i'll i'll go from a minute mark
assuming they're
just getting out of the vehicle okay
that's where we're gonna go when they're
just getting out of the vehicle
no no i will say one of the more you
know we can we can start there but
to get the full breadth of how horrific
this stop was when you know you really
need to stop and see
all you know the minute and a half of
complete compliance that my client is
delivering to these officers
before they decide to hop out and do
this but yeah go ahead and start we'll
start here
okay open the door slowly step out
open the door open the door slowly step
out open the door
now you can see his hands out the window
and if you look it's kind of
grainy here but in the top right hand
side of that
chevy tahoe's rear window and it's a
whole lot clearer on the body worn
camera footage and it's a whole lot
clearer when
officer broker gets out you can see the
window
i mean you can see the uh the license
plate
keep your hands outside the windows so
you know they're yelling get out
keep your hands off the window get out
keep your hands out the window and
there's his hands right there
he's asking what's going on now get out
of the car
now
get out of the car now now how are you
going to get out the car
right when the young ones yelling keep
your hands out the old
yell and get out the car get out of the
car now
what's going on did you fix it to ride
the lightning son now right there pause
it let's take a look
gutierrez has his pistol out trained on
my client daniel croker has his pistol
out trained on my client
and gutierrez says you are fixing to
ride the lightning son
that's completely unacceptable
i mean what would you what would you
think right you get pulled over you
think you're doing the right thing
you see two dudes with their guns
pointed at you one threatens to murder
you you're gonna get out of the vehicle
you're gonna feel comfortable with the
traffic stop
i mean i mean the thing about this is we
have to go to this is december this is
uh
right after election it's peak you know
everybody's nervous everybody's worried
what's going to be happening so i would
uh bet on being a little bit more safe
from what he's doing and he's not being
vocal he's being very
civil with them that's the part where
he's being very civil with the officers
it was surprising
how the officer with the body cam is
speaking to him and the behavior that he
is
that that's what was very surprising
about it i mean you know i think the
sergeant major the army spoke out and
said something along the lines of
lieutenant desire
and the way he comported himself in this
traffic stop was a credit to the army
and i think he's right um that's what
the sergeant major of the army said
you know he gives you a tweet you know
didn't comment on any anything that the
officers did all he commented was that
something along the lines of my you know
lieutenant nazario's comportment the way
he behaved
was a credit to the army and you know
i don't know how to take that how do you
interpret that i'm curious how do you
interpret that statement
i thought as as you know the the
sergeant major of the army saying hey
the fact that my client remained so calm
and was so polite
facing you know two hyper aggressive
officers with their guns drawn
is a credit to the training that he
received and he wanted all soldiers to
be able to behave like that under fire
that's why it's it's it's a compliment
it's a compliment
yeah okay got it let's just continue get
out of the car now
yo well guess what i'm a veteran too i'm
gonna obey get out of the car
get out of the car now let's stop it
right there you know get out of the car
work with us and we'll talk we'll work
talk to us and we'll work with you right
you know he's done nothing but be calm
and ask questions and comply up into
this point they've threatened to kill
him already and it's you know it's the
lack of self-awareness and how these
guys are behaving is mind-boggling right
this one's saying hey if you just work
with us we'll talk to you but he's
working
he's not getting out the car now because
they're threatening to murder him it
just doesn't make any sense to me
and so the reasoning have they explained
yet why they walked up to the car with
guns out is it because it took a minute
and 40 seconds until he pulled over
so we've heard a whole lot of after the
fact chatter and why they think they
might have been justified for the
traffic stop i believe they also might
have just tried to you know the
some of the more horrific things we see
with plaintiff civil rights litigation
is law enforcement trying to dig up old
bad things and try and smear the
plaintiffs and make him look bad so i
think the town of windsor might have dug
up another
traffic stop where he got a speeding
ticket um to try and make him look bad
so you know
the man's captain america um that's all
they're gonna find on
so it's uh i just forgot the question
you asked
no the question i asked is do do you
think uh the reason why they took a gun
i've been pulled over before in l.a i'm
going on 405 freeway guy comes
right next to me he's got a gun out i'm
in my black expedition i'm going 70
miles an hour
on a 65 with seven people in the car
we're all suited up we're going to a
meeting in newport a guy pulls up in a
gun i said what are you doing are you a
rookie cop i've never seen anybody take
a
gun out are you a rookie cop he after we
went to court he ended up being a rookie
cop so sometimes rookie cops
overreact and they took the gun out he
gets a little bit happy about the power
that he has
but i'm wondering what was their motive
to walk up
with a gun out rather than just walking
up saying license and registration
please
who knows you know like i said they have
this they've come up with a couple of
after the fact justifications
uh apparently crocker was some kind of
rookie cop gutierrez was there long
enough
uh both of them should know better just
out of common courtesy
but you know guterres does make a
statement that i find very problematic
it may
help to uh explain why they decided to
escalate this stuff and you know when
gutierrez is explaining to my client
that it was perfectly all right for him
to have driven to this well-lit place
and that it happens to gutierrez all the
time uh gutierrez says hey you know
i'm about you know it also tells me with
about 80 certainty that you're a
minority
so when you take a look at what led up
to that traffic altercation
and you hear that statement you know
you're trying to figure out well why
would they have done this why would they
have behaved like this
i think that particular statement for
gutierrez may hold some
fairly powerful explanatory power
got it yeah i heard the fact that it
took a
minute and 40 to pull over is the reason
why they were
worried about who this could be driving
the vehicle so they were a little bit
overreacting because it took them a long
time rather than just pulling over
so maybe that was the reason why they
overreact and they took the guns out
once that's what they're trying to spin
now but you know that's the good thing
about the bodyboard camera footage is
that's
directly contradicted by what they say
on the scene
at the time it's you know it's
that that excuse is not made in good
faith what what is the law by the way
like
meaning as an attorney if i'm being
pulled over and it cops behind me like
many times i've been pulled over it took
me 45 seconds until i felt like pulling
over to a place that i felt safe i've
done that before
i have 20 20 plus speeding tickets so
i've experienced my licenses
actually if they did the report on me
they would find license getting
suspended a couple times this guy's got
one speeding ticket
it's uh they want to pull it up and talk
about it but what is the protocol
when i am being pulled over on when to
pull over my car
so it's you know it's there i'm
i'm actually not aware of any like set
hard we call them like black letter law
that says you must pull it over with an
x y or z
right i think it's you know a factor of
you know whether it's safe
what's reasonable where you are right
you wouldn't you know you wouldn't pull
over
you know on a major freeway where
there's two jersey barriers on either
side and no shoulder that just doesn't
make any sense
so there's no real law but you know we
we are i'm taught my clients thought
a whole bunch of people i've spoken to
have also been taught um
even the chief of the windsor police
department when he was discussing was
talking about
everyone's told to pull over to you know
a safe well-lit place
so you know had he it might have
maybe for the sake of argument their
story may have held water
had there not been these these already
pre-existing indicia these signs
right that my client was
was acquiescing was submitting to their
authority whether it was lawful or not
and that factors into the legal analysis
right if you know you hit the
accelerator and zoom on what's it going
to trigger in the online of a reasonable
officer
maybe this guy is trying to rab it but
if you slow down when your lights get
hit
right you put your turn signal on and
let them know you're going to make a
left-hand turn
and you're heading for the brightest
thing in the street
and one of the officers at least says
yeah i know it happens all the time
you know that all factors into what the
officers thinking and that's how the law
is going to look at it i mean
maybe if it was four o'clock and the sun
is out rather than being dark at six
o'clock maybe it would have been a
different case
but the guy's got his bdus on him you're
talking about he's wearing his uniform
so
that ought to kind of calm your calm
your nerves down a little bit if you
don't mind i want to continue because
i want to get to the part when he
actually they spray him so let me
continue this part here
order obey it
i'm obviously afraid to get out can i
yeah you should be get out
right there he's like hey man i'm afraid
to get out the vehicle
and gutierrez was like you should be
you're gonna stop our traffic violation
you're not cooperating at this point
right now
you're under arrest for you're being
detained okay you're being contained for
obstructive justice
i can't come up with any excuse i'd love
to hear one that actually holds water
other than that
now sir look i'm trying to get out okay
i'm trying
to get out can you please relax get out
he's relaxed
get out of the car right now now this is
not how you treat a vet uh
i'm actively serving this country and
this is how you're going to treat me
i didn't do anything whoa hold on what's
going on
you know i think it's worth noting that
during that interaction and his use of
force reports which i actually find
even more problematic in the pepper
spring deputy uh
crocker and joe gutierrez say that
during that interaction
my client assaulted them
smacked their hands away right if you
want to take a look
if you want to take a look at the uh his
my client's body worn camera with my
client's cell phone footage and go back
over that footage again
it just doesn't show it so that's one of
the really problematic things
they said he smacked their hand away so
was it
yeah yeah they tried to they uh you know
at the end of all of this i don't know
if we've gotten to that part yet
um they they get him at the back of the
vehicle and they say
and i'm a paraphrase here you can go to
the videos you can go to the complaint
i've actually quoted them there
oh let me see here let me go to the
complaint
you know gutierrez and or crocker stated
that uh you know if my client
you know fought these you know they were
they could charge right they could
charge him with crimes with obstruction
with assault with the looting
um and they say that if if my client
fought what happened fought the traffic
stop
fought the uh thought the the excessive
force the violence
um which or if he argued
which they admitted at the time was his
right as a citizen they'd charge him
with crimes
and they'd let it had he'd have to go to
court he'd have to let his command know
and all do all that and gutierrez at
least by
virtue of his alleged military training
states hey
and you know the the the military is the
only place where double jeopardy doesn't
apply
implying that we're going to destroy
your career he said that at the end
yep yeah he said it at the end um he's
saying this it's exhibit five if you
want to take a look going from four
minutes and around 30 seconds to let's
say like eight or nine minutes out you
can hear this entire exchange
um and they said however you know if
lieutenant nazario would
chill and let this go you know they
wouldn't file any charges against him
they take the handcuffs off him and they
let him go
so they're doing a couple things here
right there
trying to sell this man his freedom by
making them give him his silence
and they're also saying hey check it out
if you complain about our illegal
conduct
we're going to try and destroy your
career
so that's
an incredible first amendment violation
and you know maybe they were just
popping off at the mouth right
but the problem is and the other records
show
when these officers went back to their
lawn you know the police department
they did a use of force report right
they did a reporting officer narrative
and in this use of force report
reporting officer narrative
you know daniel croker states things
like you know there were no license
plates displayed and
he knows this is false he admits it's
fault on camera um
he says you know my client willfully and
wantonly disregarded his patrol vehicles
blue lights and sirens
well that's also false and it's he says
it over the radio as he's like well he's
slowing down
23 18. and when uh when while officer
crocker attempted to unlock the
and open the driver door the driver hit
this officer's hands away
and was actively resisting um the offer
the driver
assaulted myself i.e kroger us by
assaulting my
by striking my hands away and then
pulled away from gutierrez's grip
gutierrez parrots the same stuff in his
in his subsequent uh subsequent reports
and as you just saw in that video it
didn't happen
right that's terrifying
yeah i watched the whole thing at the
end when he was selling them on the fact
that hey you can but i'm not telling you
what to do you can do whatever you want
to do it's your choice but if you do
this i know how the army works army
double jeopardy
and then he you know so what do you want
to do we can let you go we'll stay here
20 to 40 minutes and you can leave with
smoke your dog by the way what a great
name you have for your dog
i mean you see that whole thing it's
it's very
awkward very very awkward
he did not make the police department
look good i can say that let me continue
i want to see the reaction he has here
for the audience to see this so let's
let's go back to the same here
same part at this point he's been
sprayed a few times
get out of the car get out of the car
now
is making sure that they could see his
hands right he didn't even want he had
pulled his glasses off his face
he didn't want to get punched in the
face and get cut and at that point in
time he was
just concerned about keeping his hands
up not even wanting
to take your seatbelt off take yours
out now let me ask you uh uh jonathan
does he have a gun
in the glove compartment he had a gun
here right
and he was worried that maybe the
officer would see it is that one of his
fears
uh so yeah i mean you know just helped
him let's just be perfect it was yeah he
had a firearm
it was somebody it was a nine millimeter
pistol
it was legally purchased it was you know
he had a concealed carry permit
right the second amendment of the united
states says he could have it sure
um and it was in his car it was near his
console
and you know one of the things like
driver meaning the door if i open it up
it's here or is it here
it's kind of it's in like the center
there was a little it's in the center i
got it
okay and it wasn't you know it wasn't
visible from the outside the officers
wouldn't have seen it initially
um and just what kept going through his
mind is if our officer if gutierrez
right
or daniel crocker murdered him right
then and there right is because they
were they were itching to pull that
trigger from the looks of that video
the narrative would have been very
different the narrative we would have
had is you know they would have gone in
there and found that
firearm and gotten their stories
together and the narrative we would have
had was hero cop murders a black
self-defense kills a black man for
pulling a firearm on him during a
traffic stop
right that's how that narrative would
have played out so yeah he was worried
about the officers getting the gun
he was just more worried about dying at
that point in time right the gun was
secondary the gun
factors into it at the beginning and at
the end right because they
ultimately illegally search the firearm
um
reload it for him place it on his seat
and follow him up when they let him go
and he's staring down at the firearm
that they put on the seat
two officers behind him breathing down
his neck and he's got to figure out how
to move that firearm
you know because he's afraid they're
setting him up if he reaches down there
and touches that firearm again to move
it out of the seat so we can sit down
and drive away
what are they gonna do is he recording
the light
or is he recording on his phone he's
recording on his phone it's not like
live streaming
so i'm surprised they didn't stop the
recording and take the phone away
you know that might take a little bit
more situational awareness neither those
are capable of
yeah i thought about that because i'm
like if this was live this would have
been a 500 million view everybody
commenting going viral
you know a bunch of people showing up it
wouldn't look too good but it took a
minute until we saw everything that
happened so
okay so he comes can we find out a
little bit more
about uh lieutenant uh
nazario his background from my
understanding i heard him say
my grandmother is a pd nypd 30 years or
new york
police department what what he
referenced somebody in his family
this man is for all intents and purposes
captain america
right you know america could not ask for
a better son
he has extensive law enforcement in his
family
um in new york nypd i'm not going to go
any further because they may not really
appreciate that type of attention
um you know he's got extensive awards
from his time living in new york as a
youth that you know he wasn't gunning
for he was just he's
uh he's community oriented you know he
go he comes down to virginia
he goes he signs up he goes to school at
one of our prestigious
you know historically black colleges and
universities which is virginia state um
he decides that's not enough so he
enlists as a combat medic
goes and does his combat medic training
and then decides you know hey now that
i'm in the army i can do this school
thing let me apply for the really really
hard rotc
program it gets into that and retrains
as you know part of the medical core
right this man has had nothing but a
career and a life of service dedicated
to whatever community he finds himself
in
he's a the more i find out about him the
just
the more i'm impressed
politically if i would ask you is he for
defunding the police like if we were
just having a conversation at a bar is
he a guy that hates cops
okay so he is absolutely you know that's
one that he is not a man that hates cops
right he's fake you know you know what
i'm asking a question you know the
reason why i'm asking the questions
because it's like hey is there alter you
know
does he have any uh uh issues with cops
and
it doesn't feel like he does he's got
he's got law enforcement
in his family his motivation for pulling
over
to that well that place was in part to
protect those officers
you know it it he and i you know i
haven't i
also have an issue with the the term
defund the police right it's not that
we're
gonna destroy and defund them but you
know maybe some of those resources
better
are better allocated to like mental
health responders
you know maybe we shouldn't be sending
people out to conduct these traffic
stops
for license plates and or with that type
of state violence unless we're sure that
you know the death would be an accept
you know their death would be an extent
the death of the
person being detained would be
acceptable right um
you know maybe if we fund our schools
better
we have less crime you know maybe if we
were to end the disastrous war on drugs
right there you know there's
so defund the police is a loaded term
that you know i personally am not a big
fan of because it
it misses the point of reallocation of
community resources i don't know who set
it up i don't know if it was a
biden thing or a schumer thing or i
don't know who started up but
it created a momentum in span of a week
and everybody was using it
on the police you know i don't like the
term
it detracts from the the idea behind it
and you know the the probably nest is
kind of necessary reallocation and
resources but
i i haven't talked to my client but i'd
be fairly comfortable
in saying that defunding the police i.e
you know if we consider that killing
them you know
not killing the police but terminating
them abolishing them completely i
doubt he'd be behind that just doesn't
seem in keeping with his character
not understanding what he's gone through
he seemed like a guy
that loves america wants to serve his
country
gets a degree the guy says what are you
are you a specialist are you a corporal
no i'm a lieutenant i think he said i'm
a first lieutenant i don't know if he's
first or second
he said i'm a first lieutenant he said
get out the car
like wait a minute i mean i remember in
the military you know you have enlisted
i was enlisted i was an e4 when i got
out i was two and a half years i got out
i was an e4
so e4 isn't anything you know e4 is like
everybody makes e4 you didn't do
anything special to be an e4
so to say what are you on e4 it's almost
like an insult to say
what are you on e4 says i'm an officer
you salute an officer when you see them
so
and that was uh look i've seen i've seen
arguments on both sides
uh where in some instances i see the
media using stuff to divide america and
it's happened regularly it's happened a
lot especially the last 12 months
and it's pinned a lot of us against each
other i'm not for that
and i've seen issues like this where a
reasonable man who is serving the
country is being embarrassed
publicly and you're making a fool out of
yourself and these cops need to be held
accountable either it's the training
program either it's the way you handle
the issues
that's coming up but where are you at
now with this case
meaning what what direction are you
taking as
attorney and what claims are you making
if you can kind of give us an update on
where the case is at right now with him
against
the officers uh so you know we don't i'm
not gonna comment too deeply on the
ongoing litigation right i'll talk a
little bit about what's in the complaint
about the federal
process generally uh so and a little bit
of the background we filed this com we
only
filed this what is it what's today's
date
15 15. so we filed this 13 days ago
in the federal courts it was real quick
um
and we made the uh the tactical decision
because of some of my clients
lieutenant's concerns
you know we didn't tell anybody right we
kept this one quiet didn't notify the
press just filed in the court let it sit
there and
you know we get a call from uh the
virginian pilot jane harper and she's
like hey i found this
you know we're gonna run a story so we
filed this complaint you know so
that that's how and we are here today
because of that
um and i guess you know we're really
thankful for the coverage
because apparently it led to at least
one of the officers being removed
because the chief didn't seem fit that
to remove one of the officers
based on the body cam footage alone and
it's also given us a whole bunch of
outcry support which has
been really really helpful normally it's
just trolls making death threats
um that's happened too but the trolls
this time have been outweighed by uh by
the
outcry outpouring of support on both
ends of the political spectrum right
the people just say that enough and they
should
in any event so we are bringing
the complaint makes a few different
claims right there's a first amendment
claim
right for the for the violation of his
guaranteed right to petition the
government for redress of grievances
right the the the the
the core of that complaint are the
statements by gutierrez and
you know either directly or via the
presence and the failure to speak up by
croaker
um that they would destroy his military
career right
if he spoke out and tried to seek
redress for this
horrific event um they tried to bribe
him
to buy his silence with his freedom and
that's a first amendment claim
so we brought a first amendment claim
there um
we brought let me just go down the
claims here
we brought a bunch of fourth a couple of
fourth amendment claims you know a
reasonable seizure there's two
unreasonable seizure claims the first
unreasonable seizure claim is him
at some point in time the officers
lacked even
and i'm assuming here that they had it
initially and i'm not even willing to
concede that
but assuming they had this reasonable
articulable suspicion to detain him
for a license plate violation at some
point in time that had to go away
when they see it you know officer
croaker admits he sees the license plate
when he gets out of the vehicle
you have to think gutierrez saw it too
because it's visible on his body cam
before it's obscured by his firearm so
at some point in time that seizure is
unlawful
right maybe it's after they spray maybe
so they keep in the handcuffs maybe it's
from the beginning we're gonna figure
that one out in court
the second unlawful search where i'm
awful ahead so
i'm sorry that's the unlawful seizure
then we have excessive force
right so the law says sure we understand
at some point in time
officers have to use force either to
protect themselves or protect somebody
else but yeah
force is inherent in that job um
but the law generally says we're going
to look at three things right we're
going to look at what you thought they
had done
the crime and in this case it would have
been
a traffic violation right and then we're
gonna we're also gonna look at
you know whether or not the perpetrator
in this case my client um was
actively trying to resist arrest or you
know
or fighting the officers opposed to
danger to themselves or others
and then you're going to take a look at
you know whether or not
you thought there was going to be
repetition of this right
and if all of the you know those are the
facts we take a look at to determine
whether or not the violence is
appropriate
and in this case salah says the violence
was not appropriate he was complying he
had his hands out he was not a threat he
had pulled over
and it was a traffic violation so we're
bringing claims for the excessive force
now they assert similarly
illegally as well the there was a
firearm in that vehicle and that firearm
was not in plain view and even if it
wasn't playing view they would have
had a reason to think it was stolen
before they could search it so they go
in there and the video shows that the
the gutia kroker's own statement show
and then pull the firearm out it's not
for officer safety it's to run that
serial number to see if it's stolen
and to see if my client has a concealed
carry permit
so at that point in time the law is
clear when my client has been
blinded by oc spray placed in handcuffs
removed from that vehicle by yards right
on the other side of some gas pumps in
one officer's custody in handcuffs
with emts you can't go back into the
vehicle unless you're gonna search it
for
evidence of the crime you've arrested
him for
and in this case it would have either it
would have arrested him for
speeding right we're not even speeding
excuse me having a license plate there's
nothing in that vehicle that would have
been evident that's
violation of clearly established law so
that search was illegal
so we've got you know a violation of
fourth or three violations of fourth
a couple of violations of the first
amendment and then then we move on to
the state law claims right the state law
claims are just what
virginia has in their comma right the uh
the common law assault making someone
putting someone in reasonable fear
of being beaten without justification or
excuse
we've got the battery which is beating
them without justification for excuse
uh we've got some more search claims in
there and you know that's the contours
of the lawsuit
how is how is he doing right now is he
back to normal active duty or is he
what's he up to so he's
yeah it's always an interesting question
on what he's up to right
now because it implicates like army
which is because he's a priority the
only reason i ask is he is the main
person i'm concerned about because
i you know this is a guy that is a
great american that's doing his part
giving back to community i want to make
sure he goes back about his life
a normal way hey you know so he's laying
low right now right he was really really
really worried a
about filing this suit in case these
officers pulled the trigger
on their retaliation claims um now
thankfully army's been from what i
understand command's been really
supportive
so that you know booyah right that's
what you all say
who yeah yes um
and you know gutierrez is no longer a
law enforcement officer
so we have a little bit less to worry
about him pulling the trigger on that
retaliation crocker is
right crawford could always go and get
those warrants um
you know gutierrez has a whole bunch of
spare time on his hands in case he wants
to make a trip to wherever my client is
because he's seen where my he's seen my
client's address
uh you know we've also got the crazies
out there that might want to support
the state-sponsored violence no matter
how egregious and how unconstitutional
they might want to come and silence my
client so he is
you know laying low from all the viral
media attention and
i guess even beyond that
how do you react when you know your
confidence in the people that are
supposed to protect you is absolutely
shattered right
so the man does everything right the man
works out for officer safety
um the man respect for officers pulls
over
almost gets killed suffers what he
suffers at the hands of these two
officers
what does that you know
it's found it's foundationally crushing
right it alters your world perspective
and now
with the crazies coming out of the
woodwork right with office with other
law enforcement officers having real
reason to come after him
is he going to be able to call other
officers right if joe gutierrez shows up
out in front of his house who's he going
to call
he his trust in law enforcement's been
shattered
um you know luckily his dog's all right
yeah i saw that i saw that because he
was worried because the dog was uh
having a hard time breathing or you know
he was doing his best and
the way he was situated when they opened
the door at the back and he looked at
him
and i was wondering for for 15 minutes
you've had the handcuffs on why are you
keeping it on i can't take it off here
why can't you take it off yeah i'll take
it off if you agree to this
what does that have to do with me taking
it off so so by the way
why did it take from december 5th till a
week ago
for the body cam of gutierrez to be
public so we can see it
uh so you know and i'm not gonna give
the windsor police department much
credit for anything they've done right
from the way they train their officers
to really
you know the way they've refused to
issue a response
an apology to my client instead of
blaming him to
them now trying to publish video of
a speeding ticket that he got a while
ago to try and smear his name
to protect theirs i'm not going to give
them much credit i think their behavior
has been despicable
contemptible and unnecessary but what i
will say is that they were fairly quick
to release the footage without much of a
fight
um so i think i asked for the footage
from them
maybe a week after the incident and it
took a little bit longer than what the
law says they have to turn it over
but they did turn it over and you know
it took a minute to
look through the footage right and it
took a minute to actually draft the
complaint
because when you're going to start
making claims like we've made in the
complaint right
no probable cause the search the the
racial violence
the right of lightning the threats of
retaliation and the
you know the the material fault
statements in the official reports
you've really got to have your facts
straight and you've got to
document it meticulously or everyone's
going to say you're crazy
and you're going to get laughed out of
court so there was a problem
as a part of it there was a part of it
where the audio was cut for like 15
seconds and it was muted i don't know if
you remember that part it was like 28
minutes 29 minutes
where it cut out for 15 seconds and then
it came back up this is
who's whose footage was this this is the
31 minute police activity
uh footage police activity is a channel
on youtube that shows a long form and
it's the
it's on that specific channel i i guess
my question is who's was it was it law
enforcement footage
it was law enforcement's footage that
was gone for about 15 seconds
all right um so
my client's footage got interrupted
because the phone received a call while
it was recording and i guess it don't
cut off
while the call was coming and once he
couldn't answer obviously
the call cut back on um so did the
recording continue
or it stopped now his recording
continued okay the the bodywork camera
footage
won't give you audio for the first 30
seconds so it saves
there's a lag like a ping or whatever
you want to call it how it works where
it's going to save 30 minutes 30 seconds
prior in footage before you turn it on
but no audio
so for gutierrez and kroger's bodybot
camera footage the first 30 seconds of
nothing is
that's how they function i don't know
why croaker turned his off and turned it
back on
and gutierrez claims that his body-worn
camera footage got turned off during the
scuffle with my client when you know
he jumps on his back and starts beating
on him
yeah that answers your question yeah
that that
if for the viewer that hasn't seen this
obviously i'm not going to show the
whole thing to you i suggest you go look
at it it's not on my channel
it's on someone else's channel i
recommend you go take a look at it to
get a better idea for your own self
but what is the ask what is the ask that
uh you guys
are making from the state or from the
from the department
so i i love this question right because
it kind of feeds into
it there's there's all these tropes
running around that you know
plaintiff side litigators are just after
uh just after the cheddar right
and so you know there that's definitely
you know the monetary side of it's
definitely it's part of it but for for
reasons that may not be evident
and we'll get to that so first we're
asking for some declaratory relief
declaratory relief is the court saying
this conduct was unconstitutional
and we want that to add to the bulk of
case law to help other litigators
right get over qualified immunity so
that we can start holding these guys
accountable
right because really the overall goal in
these types of litigations and this lady
litigation in particular is to put a
stop to this conduct
however we have to right put a stop to
it it's got
to stop so we've got the declaratory
judgment
we are asking for money right um
in federal court in virginia it doesn't
really matter what we ask
we're going to get what the jury gives
us and you know i think we've asked for
a million dollars in compensatory
damages and then whatever the jury gives
us
impunitives and this is how this works
so the law says my client's going to be
entitled to compensation for his pain
you know for being pepper sprayed for
being beat for having his constitutional
rights violated
just to compensate him for those
injuries and that's one side of the
house
you know compensate him for the injuries
that smoke suffer right
the other side of the house are called
exemplary damages and this is what they
sound like they are sounded they're
there to make an example
and you know if
the law enforcement agencies aren't
going to change their ways not
withstanding the clearly established law
right
notwithstanding the declaratory
judgments notwithstanding the viral
reactions of the american people
then another thing we're going to do
with this lawsuit is we're going to
bankrupt them
we're going to make it so expensive to
continue to do business like this that
they are going to have to change
because the overall operation the
overall goal for this lawsuit
is to keep this from happening again it
shouldn't be happening in the first
place
but it is and we fight with the tools
we've got
interesting uh by the way you went to a
university of richmond school law you
finished in the top 15 percent of your
class you were inducted at a five day
phi delta phi
international legal honor society so you
you're somebody that finished at the top
of your class you started practice on
law in 2012 in virginia
if i have my facts right on what you do
without without checking my bio
all of that sounds sounds correct okay
your
your motivation everybody who becomes a
lawyer becomes a lawyer for a different
reason there's typically a motivation
there to become a lawyer you want to
correct
and injustice what was the motivation
for you to become a lawyer
um
you know there i think there were
different motivations for becoming a
lawyer and what i did with my law degree
so my motivations for becoming a lawyer
you know my undergrad's in philosophy i
went to vcu it's a fantastic program i
love the discipline right i love the
thought
i love the intellectual exercise
unfortunately you know
you can't eat very well on an undergrad
philosophy right
you got to go do something else so i
decided to you know to go to law school
to be able to
keep the lights on right um
why did i choose
this this type of law this type of
litigation
um and i'm with a small firm thomas h
robertson associates we got like three
litigators
and we're a really you know small
boutique civil rights firm you know we
do a whole bunch of civil rights
work first amendment fourth amendment
fifth amendment um
you know and
the question is why i don't like bullies
right um and i see
a lot of these police encounters as
bullies on steroids
right just joe gutierrez classic bully i
don't like bullies
um and i can do something about it and b
you know we are a
country of laws right
and in order to keep us from descending
into chaos
those laws have to be applied and they
have to be applied
to everyone and they have to be applied
equally
and what i kept seeing time after time
after
time was a particular element of
american society that was cloaked
with this awesome power and this awesome
responsibility abusing it not
being held accountable so i figured i'd
go into the government accountability
field
very interesting two questions that we
wrap up here one how do you feel about
cops
not like this um
you know i i have i have friends that
are i have friends that are law
enforcement i don't
dislike officers you know particularly
um
you know i trained trained at fort
leonard wood when i was in the marines
missouri we were there the only other
marine corps contingent that was there
was pmo the mps right so
throughout my time in the service i was
real close friends with military police
i don't have any problem
with the law enforcement officer and
let's say i started behaving like
gutierrez right i do but i i do have
issues with you know how we're training
them
right we seem to be training fear
into them right i have i have a problem
with us not
holding them accountable it's kind of
like mission creep right they've gone
from officer friendly to
you know something super militarized and
you know
croaker said something in that
body-worn camera footage something along
the lines of you know he had to behave
like this
because you know to them their
roe and they looked at 460 in virginia
my home
as if it was fallujah
and that is terrifying
they are not an occupying force
the roe is nothing alike
these are the citizens that they have
taken to note this
to protect so you know i
i don't like this system that has grown
up around them
and that needs to be changed fair enough
favorite philosopher since you majored
in philosophy
last question oh no no no we're talking
about we gotta go on the
middle side of the house and i anger my
analytic friends are we gonna talk about
the analytics side of the house and i'm
gonna anger my continental
friends right give me your top three top
three
top three philosophy top three so i
you know i'm a big fan of uh and i'm
gonna get crucified for this probably
you know the old-fashioned french
existentialist i really enjoy reading
albert camus for example uh i really
like the american philosophers like
david lewis and robert
nozick and some of their ethics and
metaphysical work
so you know noam chomsky gets into some
really good really interesting
his political theories are interesting
but his linguistic theories and theories
of mind are really cool too
so you know maybe those guys very cool
well listen thank you for your time
thank you for coming on to valuetainment
and i
wish you nothing but the best with this
case thank you i really appreciate the
uh
the coverage you're given to it you know
you guys are doing some real good work
we appreciate it
thank you thank you so much take care
bye-bye bye so look in case if you
haven't seen the whole thing i want to
watch the last one minute with you
and get your reaction pay attention to
the screen what happens when he gets out
of the car after he's already been
sprayed
please look this is really messed up
my dog is in the back my dog is choking
right get out of the car
take your seatbelt off what are you a
specialist corbin what are you
i'm a lieutenant lieutenant get out of
the car take your seatbelt off and get
out of the car
you made this way more difficult than it
had to be if you just comply get out of
the car
i'm reaching for my seatbelt fine take
your seatbelt off and get out of the car
straight under the ground straight onto
the ground
ma'am down let's go
let's go available get on the ground
get on the ground get on the ground now
get on the ground you're getting sprayed
again get on the ground
i can't believe he's staying reasonable
get on the ground
he's not overreacting he's being
respectful very interesting
get on the ground why am i being treated
like this
this is
so i'm curious what you think about him
he just saw the story here what happened
you can go read more articles on i'm
gonna put all the links below this has
gone viral the last seven days
everyone's talking about everyone's
showing it all over the news
but whose fault is it should lieutenant
nazareth pulled over
instead of waiting a minute 40 what
would you have done would you have gone
to a nice place that's a little bit more
bright than
six o'clock when it's dark he said i'm
going to go to the gas station would you
have just pulled over anyway by the
trees
to just kind of pull over the car what
would your have this your decision have
been secondly
did the cops overreact should they have
reacted in a completely different way
than the way that they did
especially after he puts his hand out
you see he's wearing bdu's army bdos
military bdus
maybe they should have under-reacted
instead of overreacted and by the way
this is coming from a person that just
nine months ago had
officer mark lam on sheriff mark lamont
from a tv show that got cancelled
right during the time where all the
rights was taking place and we had him
on
and he had the complete opposite
argument to say but i want to hear your
thoughts comment below
on what your thoughts are about this and
if you haven't watched my interview with
sheriff mark lam
click over here it's a 38 minute
interview that's the complete opposite
argument of him
defending police that they do the right
thing but he also calls out the ones who
don't do the right thing
haven't said that take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]